alors justement nous voyons maintenant
direct corinne lepage l'ancienne
ministre de l'environnement et avocate
de l'homme dont le cheval est mort à
cause de ces algues au mois de juillet
on l'a vu dans le reportage bonjour
madame lepage
bonjour alors sur augment de plaintes
concrètement qu'est-ce que ça va changer
ce regroupement
eh bien écoutez si regroupement i lya il
est dû au choix que nous avons fait que
monsieur petit de saisir le procureur de
la république de paris et plus
précisément le pôle santé environnement
du dossier pourquoi
et bien tout simplement parce qu'il nous
semblait que c'était un dossier complexe
technique qui impose et que des
magistrats qui en avait une grande
habitude des experts depuis s'en saisir
eux plutôt qu'il soit inscrit par un e
parquet local
quel que soit ce parquet les qualités et
quel que soit le juge d'instruction qui
aurait été nommé et ses qualités parce
que tout simplement les mêmes moyenne
était pas leur disposition et plus de
moyens ça signifierait quoi finalement
pardon plus de moyens qu est ce que ça
changerait pour les pour les plaignants
qu'est-ce que ça
en quoi ça va améliorer les choses il a
écouté le le regroupement qui est la
suite logique de ce que je viens de dire
va permettre effectivement au pôle santé
d'ordonner des expertises alors comment
les choses vont-elles se passer je ne
sais pas si le choix du procureur
aujourd'hui et d'ouvrir une information
ou de saisir immédiatement un juge
d'instruction à l'heure qu'il est je
n'ai pas la réponse à la question mais
la logique voudrait que de toute façon
ça se termine dans le cabinet d'un juge
d'instruction qui est un juge spécialisé
dans ce type de dossier et qui lui-même
nommera les experts qui lui sembleront
nécessaires pour parvenir à la
manifestation de la vérité selon la
formule consacrée
elle parlait d'une affaire d'état dans
ce reportage vous êtes d'accord avec
avec ce terme une affaire politicienne à
le faire des tas non c'est pas une
affaire d'état c'est pas c'est pas paris
parce que c'est une affaire d'état c'est
à paris parce que c'est à paris qu'il y
a le pôle santé environnement s'il avait
été à brest la sphère serait à brest
cela dit ça fait 30 ans qu'on n'a rien
fait dans cette histoire ça va peut-être
changer les choses oui ça ça c'est une
autre chose ça c'est une autre chose
c'est vrai que les algues vertes c'est
très vieux
lorsque j'ai eu l'honneur de défendre
les bretons moment là
au coq à 10 avec sql en 78 kg avait déjà
des algues vertes
voilà donc ça fait un sacré moment que
cette affaire la dure et qu'elle n'a pas
été traitée il faut dire les choses
comme elles sont et on espère
effectivement ce sera de manière
sérieuse le coeur mais ce qui est
nouveau voyez vous c'est l'aspect
sanitaire
merci beaucoup madame lepage pour ces
précisions et en duplex de paris